this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out Squarespace
through the link in the description
below more on them a bit
[Music]
Charles Ponzi allegedly once said I went
looking for trouble and I found it
truer words were never spoken from an
early age Ponzi discovered that hard
work and book learning were not for him
he was always involved in one scheme
after another hoping that someday he
would find the one thing that would make
him rich beyond his wildest dreams he
turns out to be right one day Charles
Ponzi was struck by a lightning bolt of
perfidious inspiration and set in motion
one of the most brazen and ambitious
cons in history the basic concept behind
the swindle even took his name sure
people like loupe Armand and Bernie
Madoff employed the fraud a far greater
success and as we will find out he
wasn't even the first one to do it but
even today the con is still remembered
as the Ponzi scheme
the conman lured his victims with the
simple but irresistible promise of quick
and easy money but this was one
temptation that Ponzi himself could not
control he kept on scheming and plotting
even when his walls of lies were
crashing down around him and the end was
inevitable ultimately his deceitful ways
cost him everything his money his wife
his friends his freedom and he ended up
dying penniless in a Charity Hospital in
Brazil today we look at Charles Ponzi
the con man who experienced the highest
of highs followed by the lowest of lows
Charles Ponzi was born Carlo Pietro
Giovanni googly motive Aldo Ponzi on
March the 3rd 1882 in the town of Lugo
in northern Italy his parents were
arrest and Imelda Ponzi hello
information on Ponzi's early years comes
from the man himself from interviews
that he gave after he became a national
celebrity as well as his boastful
autobiography as you might imagine there
is an inherent risk when you take a con
man at his word but we have little
choice F according to Ponzi his family
it was once well-off and lived in Parma
that had fallen on hard times prior to
his birth at one point he relocated to
Rome and took on odd jobs before being
accepted to the Sapienza University of
Rome by his own admission Ponzi was not
exactly a conscientious student instead
he preferred to hang around bars and
cafes with his rich friends as he put it
spending money seemed the most
attractive thing on earth unsurprisingly
the good times did not last long and
after a few years Ponzi was forced to
leave the university with no money and
no to play map eat heard stories of
other Italians who went off to America
to find fame and fortune and decided
that this was the only course open to
him on November 15 in 1903
Charles Ponzi arrived in Boston Harbor
aboard the SS Vancouver again going by
his accounts he only had two dollars and
fifty cents in his pockets because he
lost the rest of his money playing cards
during the transatlantic crossing
however he did have 1 million dollars in
hopes even so his climb towards the top
was long and slow and it started with a
bunch of odd jobs up and down the East
Coast
he worked as a busboy a waiter or a sign
painter but never lasted in one position
long because he always got in trouble
for stealing or trying to cheat the
customers after a few years of this
Ponzi moved to Canada and settled in
Montreal in 1907 he found a job as an
assistant teller with zorroski bank new
business opened to cater to the recent
influx of Italian immigrants here Ponzi
managed to rise through the ranks
quickly because he was charming and
outgoing and could speak multiple
languages he might
been able to launch a successful career
as a banker if not for the fact that the
owner of the bank Luigi Rossi was
operating his own scam he attracted new
clients with generous interest rates on
bank deposits except that he was paying
on those interests using the money
deposited into new accounts meanwhile he
used the profits for real estate loans
eventually the scheme failed and
zorroski fled to Mexico
Ponzi was once again penniless he forged
a cheque for 220 $3.58 and got caught he
ended up serving three years a sum
vincent depaul Federal Penitentiary in
Montreal before returning to the United
States back in Boston it did not take
long for Ponzi to get involved in
another criminal endeavor this time it
was smuggling Italian immigrants across
the border he was caught again and spent
another two years in prison after
becoming a free man again it seems the
Ponzi tried to walk the straight and
narrow at least for a little while
perhaps part of the reason was rose
Gannett so a young woman he met on a
streetcar one day and fell in love with
Ponzi wooed her endlessly and soon
enough the innocent girl was enamored
with his charm and apparent
sophistication but who got married in
1918 during that time Ponzi worked first
as a teller for a broker junior pool ins
afterwards left to take over his
father-in-law's grocery store
neither endeavor proved successful and
soon enough Charles Ponzi was looking
for a new garage quick scheme
[Music]
[Applause]
even if you've never heard of Charles
Ponzi before this video chances are that
you were at least familiar with the scam
that shares his name the Ponzi scheme
but what exactly doesn't involve a Ponzi
scheme is an investment fraud that
relies on the old adage rob Peter to pay
Paul
the basics of the court involved paying
off the dividends of older investors
with money from new investors people
think their money gets invested wisely
and profitable business ventures and
that the person in charge is really just
rather good at their job most of the
funds however go straight into the
pocket of the schema in exchange the
victims get some money back which in
their minds represents the profits that
they made from legitimate transactions
as far as they are concerned the bulk of
their investment is still safe and sound
not realizing that it's already gone
used to pay off other investors and to
finance a luxurious lifestyle for the
con artist the biggest drawback of the
Ponzi scheme is that it requires a
constant flow of new investors to pay
off the earlier ones if the well runs
dry the scam falls apart that is why
these swindlers do their best to ensure
a steady supply of new funds by
promising huge profits with no risks
this turns the scam into a bit of a
vicious cycle the more profits the
conman pays out the more new money needs
to come in which in turn raises the
amounts of profits being paid out which
results in the need for new investors
and so the cycle continues once a Ponzi
scheme is set in motion it doesn't
really stop until it crashes and burns
and the fraud is exposed even so a
skillful conman can keep it going for
years even decades there is usually no
shortage of people unable to resist the
allure of fast and easy money the Ponzi
scheme gets generally mixed up with the
pyramid scheme and although the two are
very similar there are a few key
differences most importantly in the
Ponzi scheme the fraudster acts as a
sole operator and interacts with all of
his targets directly in a pyramid scheme
however participants need to recruit
others into the fray in order to gain
any benefits thus creating a layer of
separation between them and the original
fraudster every time moreover a Ponzi
scheme promises the victims profits
through obscure methods of in
investment while pyramid scheme
participants know from the outset that
their returns come from signing up new
members generally a Ponzi scheme is more
durable because it requires fewer people
to stay afloat although Charles Ponzi's
name is inexorably attached to this type
of con he was not the first to employ a
former German actress named Adele spade
Sarah might lay claim to that title
after opening a bank in 1871 and using
this method to pay off her investors her
scam lasted a little over a year but was
soon followed by austrian johann baptist
plaqued whose fraud was discovered in
1874 in America Sarah Howell might be
the first to employ this technique in
1879 she opens a bank named the ladies
deposit company in Boston which offered
large interest rates on deposits she
claimed to have backing from a quake
charity but was simply using money from
new depositors to pay off the interest
rates another notable swindler was
William five hundred and twenty percent
Miller who operated the Franklin
syndicate he defrauded 1 million dollars
in 1890s money before being caught there
are some red flags which the United
States Securities and Exchange
Commission or SEC say can help investors
avoid ponzi schemes they include the
promise of unreasonably high returns
with no risk consistent returns
regardless of the state of the market
shady paperwork unlicensed sellers and
secretive or complex investment
strategies if it sounds too good to be
true while it usually is except of
course when it comes to today's sponsor
Squarespace
if you thought making your website was
complex and expensive just not something
you could do well think again now maybe
you've got some idea for a website or a
business or a Ponzi scheme or something
else and knocking around in your mind
just kidding about the Ponzi scheme
thing don't do that
well it's about time you stopped sitting
on that idea and you've got it out into
the world now that might be scary but
you know new things are but not knowing
how to set up a website is not an excuse
no excuse is available with Squarespace
which make it incredibly easy to set up
a website Squarespace allows you to
create a powerful website for whatever
you're up to want to sell something
online easy podcast absolutely starting
a YouTube channel well obviously you do
that on YouTube but you'll want a
website to complement it it all starts
on Squarespace with a beautiful template
that you can customize
to your heart's content or you can start
from scratch or easily move over from an
existing domain making everything super
easy to manage don't start from scratch
though that's my advice just use one of
their beautiful templates like I said no
excuses with Squarespace and once you've
gone through the super easy
customization process there's no updates
there's no patches
there's no tech vs to deal with and
Squarespace also hands on all of the
website e stuff like I said there's
podcasts but they also do mailing lists
social integrations all of that good
stuff and of course 24/7 customer
support if you need it at de
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash playa
graphics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain and
let's get back to mr. Ponzi now we have
a general idea of what a Ponzi scheme is
how exactly did Charles Ponzi's specific
scam work well it was based around a
special post or coupon known as an
international real a coupon or IRC it
was introduced in 1906 and it was meant
to be exchanged for the postage stamp
necessary to send one single rate
ordinary delivery between two countries
which were members of the Universal
Postal Union or un-you in other words a
person from the United States let's call
in Jack sends a letter to Murray in
France he wanted a reply but was not
expecting Murray to spend her own money
on postage stamps to write back to him
therefore he also included with the
original letter an IRC which he bought
in the US which Murray could redeem in
her own country for the postage
necessary to send back another letter
Ponzi had never heard of these coupons
until he received one from a company in
Spain he'd written many letters to
businesses in Europe presenting various
ideas of his and this company wrote back
to him and included an IR Steve has
replied whatever money-making pitch
Ponzi originally made to the Spanish
company was quickly forgotten because he
had a new idea
Ponzi realized than inflation mainly
caused by World War one meant there was
a slight but noticeable difference in
the value of the stamps which were
exchanged using IR C's the redemption
rate of these coupons was fixed through
an international treaty but one could
theoretically make a profit if they
bought IR C's in the differ
country using currency that had fallen
against the dollar then exchanging them
for stamps in the United States and then
selling those stamps in US currency
Ponzi code for example by an IRC in a
Spanish post office worth thirty
centavos he could then exchange it in
the US for a stamp worth five cents and
make a ten percent profit if he scaled
up this operation he could earn
substantial dividends the profit would
be even greater if he bought IR C's from
the countries with the highest inflation
basically what Ponzi wanted was a type
of arbitrage which simply means
purchasing something in one market and
then selling it in another markets where
the price is higher this was not only
common profitable but it was also
perfectly legal
Ponzi had his sales pensions now he
needed people to invest he made bold
claims of having agents all over Europe
who were buying up our season bulk and
sending them back to him so he could
exchange and sell them for a profit he
boasted that he could provide returns on
investments of 50 percent in 45 days or
a hundred percent in 90 days any
requests for additional details would
have been denied on the basis that it
could help the competition in reality
setting up such an operation would have
been so costly that it would have
completely negated any profits made from
selling IR C's not to mention the fact
that there were nowhere near enough post
or coupons in the world to sustain a
business the size that Ponzi's would
reach but these weren't details that
concerned his clients at first Ponzi
tried the banks but they were not biting
and refused to grant him loans for this
new business however he founds
considerably more success simply
appealing to the general population who
proved more inclined to believe his
tales of easy riches at first he mainly
appealed to friends and acquaintances
like his biographer donald dunn argued
Ponzi's biggest talents had nothing to
do with being good with finances but
rather being good with people he made
sure not to be too aggressive with his
pictures he casually flaunted his
success and only went into detail when
pressed by others then if they
absolutely insisted he would take their
money in January 1920 Ponzi started the
securities exchange company by then that
money had begun rolling in and the
swindler had a supply of investors
launching his own business was the
natural next step as well as a necessary
move in order to attract new clients and
keep delivering those promised returns
soon enough he relocated to a bigger
office on Boston's School Street to the
site of the first public school in the
United States
[Music]
it wasn't long before Ponzi was handling
millions of dollars from tens of
thousands of investors people were
lining up around the block to give their
money to this financial wizard who came
out of nowhere and at the secret to
untold wealth at the height of his
success Ponzi was making around two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a day
obviously this newfound success allowed
him to indulge in a lavish lifestyle
he bought a spacious 12 room mansion in
Lexington Massachusetts he rode around
town in a custom-built chauffeured
limousine wearing expensive tailored
suits with diamond type-ins and carrying
around gold handled cane some of his
more lavish expenditures included buying
a bank which had previously rejected his
loan application as well as pools
brokerage firm where he used to work
just so that he could fire his former
boss the good times lasted less than a
year for Ponzi before he got caught and
looking back it's surprising that it
even took that long he might have been
an incredible salesman but Ponzi was not
a skilled financier like Bernie Madoff
for example he could keep his scam going
for decades in fact Ponzi's own
publicist later called him a financial
idiot who couldn't even at the scheme
did not stand up to scrutiny from a
person who knew what they were talking
about
however Ponzi managed to delay
investigations first by successfully
suing a financial right of a libel which
acted as a deterrence to other
journalists and then by sweet-talking
state officials and easing their growing
suspicions Ponzi's world came tumbling
down in the summer of 1920 mostly
courtesy of the Boston Post which even
won the Pulitzer Prize for public
service for the exposure of Ponzi's
operations however credit is also due to
William McMasters the man Ponzi hired as
his publicist shortly before his
downfall
[Music]
at first the relationship between the
three started off great
one of McMasters first acts as Ponzi's
publicist was to schedule him an
interview with the Boston Post which at
the time at the largest circulation in
New England on July the 24th a piece on
Ponzi appeared on the newspapers front
page it detailed his rags to riches
story and how he was able to provide all
of his investors with amazing returns
that no other financier could come close
to on July the 26th a Monday Ponzi went
to his office to find a massive line of
people waiting to give him their money
in just that one day Ponzi collected
over three million dollars which is
about thirty four million dollars in
today's money this huge success it came
with drawbacks as it made Ponzi
front-page news all over the country the
Boston Post in particular now at a
strong interest in him concurrently
McMasters began doubting his clients
claims realizing it would have been
impossible for anyone to deliver the
type of returns that Ponzi promised
eventually McMasters became convinced
that his client was a fraud and began
working with the post to expose him the
newspapers acting publisher Richard
Grazia was initially wary of the idea
because he feared a lawsuit but
McMasters got him on board with help of
district attorney Nathan Taft sue
promised him immunity from lawsuits if
the expose proved false on August the
second the Boston Post ran a
first-person accounts written by
McMasters which had the headline
declares Ponzi is now hopelessly
insolvent the publicist proclaimed that
Ponzi was at least two million dollars
in debt and up to 4.5 million if you
took into accounts the interest on his
outstanding notes the downfall became
very quick for Ponzi he tried reassuring
his investors and lashing out at his
accusers but there was no way to stop
the government auditors from looking at
his books on August the 11th the post
further hurried his demise by revealing
that Ponzi spent time in prison in
Canada for forging checks an official
report from the US Post Office revealed
that Ponzi never cashed in any ir C's in
the United States while an audit
concluded that he was three million
dollars later revised to seven million
dollars in debt Charles Ponzi was
arrested on federal charges of mail
fraud his downfall led to the collapse
of six banks and caused the financial
ruin of
of thousands of people who received less
than 30 cents on the dollar on their
investments initially Ponzi only served
three and a half years in prison before
being released on parole however he was
immediately arrested again on state
charges of larceny and sentenced to
another seven to nine years in prison
Ponzi appealed the state conviction was
released on bail until the matter was
settled immediately fled to
Massachusetts and ended up in
Jacksonville Florida despite the
complete collapse of his financial house
of cards
Ponzi had no intention of turning
straight as he said in his autobiography
no man is ever licked unless he wants to
be and I didn't intend to stay licked he
immediately got started on another scam
which meant to take advantage of the
real estate boom in Florida he founded
the sharp on lamb syndicate and sold
property to oblivious investors who were
lured in by Ponzi's charm and his
promises of huge returns on valuable
tracts of land in just a few months what
they soon discovered was that what they
actually purchased was worthless swamp
lands and property that was actually
underwater Ponzi was arrested again
however before the authorities fully
realized who they were dealing with he
posted bail and went on the run once
more this was one too many close calls
for the con man and he decided to escape
to Italy he shaved his head and mustache
and secured passage as a crewman aboard
a merchant ship headed for Europe
however his identity was discovered and
Ponzi was arrested in the Port of New
Orleans
[Music]
this time there was no more escaping for
the Supreme swindler he served seven
years in prison was released in 1934 and
then was deported to Italy because Ponzi
never actually obtained his American
citizenship the final years of his life
are not well documented because they
were not covered in his autobiography
and also because the world lost interest
in Charles Ponzi the man who left prison
was not the same one who entered it
Ponzi had lost his youth his confidence
and his guile his wife did not follow
him to Italy and they divorced a few
years later Ponzi didn't last long in
his mother lands and ended up in Brazil
according to one version of events this
was because he got caught conning people
again and had to go on the run another
version said that a cousin of his who
worked in the Air Force got him a job
with an airline that ran flights between
Italy and Brazil the gig only lasted a
few years though as the fledgling
airline was closed when results sided
with the Allies during World War two
Charles Ponzi spent the last few years
of his life in squalor working as a
teacher and translator to make ends meet
a stroke left him partially blind and
paralyzed he died on January the 18th
1949 in a Charity Hospital in Rio de
Janeiro
leaving behind barely enough money to
cover his burial so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit the thumbs up button below
and don't forget to subscribe we got
brand new videos four times a week
also why not check out our sister
channel Geographics this channel is
about people that channel is about
places it is linked to below and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]